[Music]
on this Thursday night Ukraine's hunt
for people collaborating with the
Kremlin from doctors to tax collectors
and teachers she taught that hair song
and belonged to Russia Global's Jeff
Semple reports from her song
he's future
commissioner Brenda Leckie leaves
serious problems why making any
meaningful changes could be difficult
clearing the air the American president
on those flying objects shot down
and their goal is equal pay this is the
time for them to push back the Canadian
women's soccer teams fight for a Level
Playing Field
National with Donna freezing
thanks for joining us we begin tonight
in Ukraine with an inside look at how
collaborators and informants are being
tracked down ukrainians accused of
siding With the Enemy they have helped
geolocate targets for Russian forces
even managed to infiltrate senior roles
in government thousands have been
detained in the past year and hundreds
of court cases have been opened in the
city of hersan which was under Russian
control for months searching for the
Enemy Within is deeply personal our Jeff
Semple was there and has our top story
tonight
[Applause]
a Sunday memorial service in Ukraine
held in the shadow of an atrocity this
apartment building was obliterated last
month by a Russian missile killing 45
people
including svetlana's husband a father of
two
he always made us laugh and smile
everyone loved him she says compounding
her grief news that seven ukrainians
were arrested
[Music]
police released this video of the raid
the suspects accused of helping the
Russian military plan its attack one of
them is a co-worker of svetlana's sister
I hate them all of them she says they're
traitors who will do anything for money
across Ukraine police are hunting for
Russian collaborators and perhaps
nowhere more than in the southern city
of her son the Russians occupied the
city of her son for nearly nine months
and Ukrainian authorities believe they
had help from the inside across this
region now you'll see signs and
billboards like this one with different
ways for ukrainians to contact the
authorities if they know someone who
helped the Russians
since liberating her son in November
Ukrainian authorities have launched
hundreds of Investigations into suspects
from all walks of life from tax
collectors who demanded mandatory
payments from residents for the Russians
to police officers charged with torture
of pro-ukrainian activists
at this Children's Hospital the medical
director is accused of helping the
Russians by refusing to allow cancer
patients to be transferred outside
russian-occupied territory
we had children who needed special
treatment abroad and he would not allow
us to transport them we could only send
them to Russia this doctor says
several her son government officials are
also accused of helping to organize
September's sham referendums on
annexation
the occupiers created their own illegal
institutions including local government
and police this Ukrainian prosecutor
says they also committed treason in the
information Sphere for example he points
to this local school teacher
after the Russians took control she was
appointed her son's new Director of
Education and led the implementation of
a new pro-russian curriculum
she replaced the Ukrainian symbols and
books with Russian propaganda the
prosecutor says she taught that her son
belonged to Russia
prosecutors also charged a local
journalist Olenna cholastenko she gave
interviews on Russian State TV and
launched a newspaper claiming Russian
soldiers were Heroes rescuing her son
from Ukraine's fascist regime
she claimed the city's anti-russian
protests were fake and after escaping to
Russia herself she reported that
Ukrainian Nazis and her son were
executing civilians Global News spent a
few days in her son and found no
evidence to support any of her claims
instead we found a city under constant
Russian shelling
she helped to promote the false
narrative in Russian media to justify
The Invasion claiming that we wanted the
Russians here says this local journalist
the truth she says is that many people
in this Russian speaking city used to
feel close ties to Russia but not
anymore
The Invasion changed that she says he
United the city against Russia in a
statement shall the stenko accused
global news of pursuing the goal of not
seeing the Nazis in the armed forces of
Ukraine and accused Ukrainian
authorities of conducting a Witch Hunt
we asked her son's prosecutor if their
investigations into the collaborators
were going too far
this is not true we have very fair
criminal law in Ukraine he says
also you can see the physical results of
their work with the Russians destroyed
buildings and loss of life
in a city of three hundred thousand the
number of those accused of collaborating
with the Russians is relatively small
but the Damage Done to their neighbors
through their actions is impossible to
measure Jeff Semple Global News her son
and the damage from Russian attacks on
Ukraine is Relentless officials say at
least 36 missiles were launched in the
past day targeting infrastructure
Canada's foreign affairs minister
Melanie Jolie has now left Kiev she was
there for talks with Ukraine's president
she says Canada is backing plans for a
special tribunal to investigate war
crimes committed by Russia and she
announced more than 21 million dollars
in humanitarian Aid
this will include work like demining the
streets playgrounds and Fields and
helping to address the psychological
impact this war has had on Ukrainian
people
Jolie says much of the money will go to
local organizations including helping
respond to cases of War related sexual
violence
in turkey and Syria the number of debt
is still climbing by the thousands every
day over 42 000 people are now known to
have lost their lives and the
humanitarian crisis is urgent relief
organizations are asking the world to
step up the U.N has launched an appeal
for one billion dollars in Aid to help
earthquake victims in Turkey earlier
this week it requested nearly 400
million for Syria the Red Cross has
tripled its request for Aid it says it
needs over 700 million dollars to
respond to the soaring humanitarian
needs in both countries some Canadians
with family in the earthquake zone are
hoping the federal government will step
up to help Ross Lord reports
for earthquake survivors like this
teenage girl who spent 10 days trapped
in rubble a better future is far from
guaranteed members of the antebbe family
are living in the street in gazian
Turkey their house survived but it's
been declared unsafe to live in they're
selling personal items to buy food and
sleeping in a park a bleak existence
felt by other family members in Halifax
my grandson Omar without like any roof
and their children there is like elderly
people when Omar and his family came to
Canada as Syrian refugees in 2016 the
rest of the family moved to Turkey he's
urging the federal government to help
reunite them if the government has
chosen them to come to Halifax
or even like Toronto
like it doesn't matter for us at least
like leave the country because it's not
safe there anymore his younger siblings
share his concerns I've been really
upset me too and very anxious there are
similar wishes from Canadian families
enduring even worse hardship Muhammad
azmal nixad of Calgary lost his mother
and a sister in the earthquakes two
other siblings in Turkey survived but
are now disabled any kind of fast track
visas that I picked them out there and
taking care of them because
they need emotional support you need
treatments do you need to
if I leave them out here there's no one
to take care of them and I will probably
lose both of them
I just
kindly request them
to do something for them at least as a
human
I will take care of them out in Calgary
I will work there not
if I have to in a statement the
department of citizenship and
immigration was non-committal saying
it's watching the situation very closely
adding Canada tailors each response to
meet the unique needs of those who
require our support
a long way to go before the grief and
disarray Jesus
Ross Lord Global News
now to the mystery objects shot down
over Canadian and American airspace the
RCMP today suspended The Surge for the
object shot down over Lake Huron citing
deteriorating weather and the low
probability of recovery the search
continues for the one shot down over
Yukon and today the U.S president said
those two plus the one downed over
Alaska were likely privately owned and
not conducting surveillance
the intelligence community's current
assessment is that these three objects
were most likely balloons tied to
private companies Recreation or research
institutions studying weather or
conducting other scientific research
Biden was under increasing pressure to
explain why they were shot down he
offered no in new information not all
balloons are spy balloons this website
for example tracks amateur balloons
called Pico balloons they are launched
all over the world and some circle the
globe flying at high altitudes
there is a big change coming to the RCMP
now that commissioner Brenda lucky has
announced she is leaving her replacement
has not been named yet but Canada's
Public Safety Minister said today he
hopes whoever gets the job takes the
force to newer Heights Mackenzie gray
reports
in its 150th year the RCMP is primed for
yet another major change commissioner
Brenda lucky set to leave her post next
month it hasn't been an easy time in
Canada or for the RCMP but I appreciate
very much all her leadership and wish
her the very best for the years to come
a 37-year veteran of the forest lucky
was the first woman appointed as
commissioner and she billed herself as a
reformer I plan to challenge assumptions
seek explanations and better understand
the reasons how we operate
but changing an organization of nearly
30 000 employees proved difficult and
potential progress stalled by multiple
missteps heavily criticized for her
handling of the Nova Scotia mass
shooting and alleged political
interference lucky also irked Advocates
on review of systemic racism after
George Floyd's murder you know it's a
question
I haven't been struggling with but I've
been struggling with the definition of
systemic racism Rank and file mounties
struggled internally with class action
lawsuits served against the force for
racism sexual assault and bullying if
racist Behavior takes place inside a
police organization that racist Behavior
will eventually make its way to the
citizens on the street
the scope of the RCMP also causing
concern from policing rural highways to
investigating terrorism the mounties
broad mandate makes implementing
meaningful change difficult when you
look at the rcmp's ability to to
demonstrate
responsiveness to community concerns
public concerns or even governmental
concerns their track record is abysmal
another issue lucky was criticized for
her advice to the government on how to
handle the Convoy protest and we'll
learn more about that tomorrow Donna
when the commission looking at the use
of the emergencies act tables its final
report
okay Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thank you
Toronto police say a 15-year-old student
is fighting for his life tonight after
he was shot in the parking lot of a high
school this afternoon this victim was
shot in the chest area or the upper
chest area after he was shot he ran back
into the school the victim ran back into
the school where he was tended to by
teachers and faculty at the school
it happened at Western Collegiate
Institute the boy was brought to
hospital in critical condition the
school was locked down for about two
hours police say the suspect suspect or
suspects escaped in a vehicle and
they're asking for home security or dash
cam footage from the area
growing outrage in Ohio coming up the
fury and frustration after a dangerous
train derailment
there was anger at a town hall meeting
in East Palestine Ohio last night more
than a week after a fiery trained
derailment of cars carrying toxic and
hazardous chemicals I don't care about
anything else I don't care about giving
reports on TV I you know because I want
you all safe I don't want 50 cameras
around me I want to be watching a
basketball game here watching my kids
play in this gym
the town's mayor tried to reassure
residents who aren't convinced enough
testing has been done to ensure it's
safe for them to return home
representatives from the train operator
did not show up at the meeting saying
they're worried about physical threats
to their employees since being allowed
to return home some residents have
complained of unexplained headaches
coughs and Dead Fish and small animals
State Health officials say all the
testing done so far has revealed no
safety issues
to the Bahamas Now where prime minister
Justin Trudeau met leaders from across
the Caribbean and made new pledges to
support the region his biggest priority
is Haiti a country racked by
out-of-control gang violence and
political instability the Prime Minister
says Canada will deploy Naval vessels to
the Haitian coast and send 20 million
dollars in humanitarian Aid durye isri
reports on why help is so badly needed
[Music]
a new set of eyes will soon be on the
coast of Haiti a country plunging deeper
into chaos the Royal Canadian Navy is
deploying Patrol ships off the Waters of
Port-au-Prince they'll conduct
surveillance and gather intelligence
prime minister Justin Trudeau made the
pledge at caracom Caribbean leaders
invited him as a special guest in part
to try to contain the security crisis in
Haiti we have seen in the past that the
presence of a coast guard ships or ships
there from allies significantly
dissuaded The Gangs armed gangs are
unleashing extreme violence kidnappings
rapes and murders have surged since the
Haitian president's assassination in
2021 Canada sent a military plane
earlier this month to back Nation police
Haiti's unelected prime minister met
with Trudeau in Nassau
Arielle Henry warned the security
situation is deteriorating Ahi and U.N
officials are calling for an
international National Ground Force with
the U.S suggesting Canada Take the Lead
the Bahamas and Jamaica are willing to
send troops but so far Canada is not if
some Canadian Armed Force or police
officer are killed in confrontation
in Haiti what will be the reaction of
Canadian people many Haitians and people
across the Caribbean are skeptical the
long sad story of Haiti has been
everybody and anybody jumping in and
trying to take control
of civil unrest Civil War and just
making an utter mess of it political
scientists believe the first priority
should be holding free and fair
elections The Dilemma is that in the
meantime
a lot of Haitians are suffering 90
Sailors will be on board the two vessels
headed to Haiti but the deployment comes
at a time when military experts say the
Navy is strapped for resources Donna
crituria Israeli in the Bahamas thanks
persistent problem ahead exploring why
lowering the rate of inflation is such a
challenge
after nearly a year of successive hikes
to interest rates inflation still isn't
slowing down as quickly as policy makers
initially hoped and gaviola explains why
this problem has been so hard to tame
all around her reminders of sticker
shock my favorite
asparagus seven dollars for us because
it's it's ridiculous as a senior living
on a fixed income it is especially tough
food inflation continues to soar but
overall inflation is changing the price
of goods Furniture household appliances
and cars coming down but services are
heating up prices at the restaurant
prices to go on an airplane a personal
care services those prices are more tied
to
um the labor market and the fact that we
miss a lot of people working in these
industries now that in a nutshell is why
inflation has been so persistent there
are signs it peaked in the summer but
getting inflation closer to the bank of
Canada's two percent target has taken
longer than policy makers hoped it might
not be problematic economically but
politically you can't just keep telling
the smallest cohort of workers that we
have seen in 60 years no you can't even
catch up to the price of goods that's
just a that's a no-fly zone politically
nearly a year of interest rate hikes
from the central bank to raise the cost
of borrowing slow down the economy and
in turn cool inflation hasn't yet done
the trick Canadian borrowing rates don't
affect global Transportation costs
climate damaged crops or a war in
Ukraine but most economists agree
inflation must be tackled because those
who earn the least are most affected so
when will there be relief in sight it's
a moving Target probably early next year
inflation will have come back down to at
least close to to where the the Bank of
Canada would like them to be with right
now there's no consensus on whether High
interest rates will lead the economy
into a recession either and gaviola
Global News Toronto
fight for equality next the tense labor
dispute between Canada Soccer and its
National Women's team
[Music]
demanding equal treatment and funding is
not a new battle for women in sport and
right now it's Canada's women's soccer
team who are in the fight they won gold
at the 2020 Olympics but still find
themselves exhausted and deflated by a
labor dispute team captain Christine
Sinclair says they are getting on with
the game playing under protest at a
tournament in Florida yesterday they
wore their Canadian soccer jerseys
inside out during a training session
Heather York's West explains why the
team is taking the fight for equal
funding and treatment to the
international stage
on a day they're facing their biggest
Rivals Canada's national women's soccer
team is fighting an even bigger battle
off the pitch with their own sports
Federation I mean I think we've made it
pretty clear that we're operating on our
protest at the minute right now it's the
most the team can do their strike notice
over the weekend was met with the threat
of legal action from Canada Soccer
forcing the squad back to work the team
says it's not treated as equals
alongside the national men's team not
just in how players are compensated but
how the national program is funded as a
whole soccer has really grown in the
last 10 years thanks mainly I would say
to the Canadian women's soccer program
there's more eyeballs more sponsors more
money
so where's it going right in a brief
statement Thursday Canada Soccer said
it's working to address the team's
requests if a resolution isn't reached
team captain Christine Sinclair says
more job action will follow there's a
FIFA window coming up in April
um
where you know we have said that if
things are not just addressed if things
aren't fixed
we will not be going to that camp this
could be our most important fight that
we ever have uh as national team players
and it's one we're determined to win the
teams fight for pay and funding Equity
is something Elite female athletes have
been struggling with for years but some
say this is the team and the time to
make a lasting change this is the right
time and this is the right team the
women are coming off of a phenomenal
gold win in Tokyo
um you know women's soccer there's such
a big momentum of the the culture of
soccer even their Rivals agree I
remember talking about the Olympic
Champions here to have their Federation
you know meet them this way after
winning world championship is just wild
to me the world already knows the women
of Canadian soccer have nerves of Steel
now they're letting Canada Soccer know
this is one Showdown they're determined
to win
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your Canada is headingley Manitoba I
know that spot thanks for watching for
our Nazar will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and I'll see you Saturday for
the new reality bye-bye
foreign